damn statin is named after the German
town damn start which is where the big
German accelerator is situated a letter
arrived from Germany from the Institute
where they've made all the elements from
a hunt and second up to 112 and all
being well I want to go and visit the
Institute so that we can actually see
where these elements be made
so when dumped out in Germany where they
made six different super-heavy elements
and I'm just going to show you how they
did it so imagine that this tree here is
a leg Target full of atoms and here I've
got lots of atom of the lighter elements
say copper or iron and I throw it and it
doesn't stick and you go on throwing and
throwing more and more and eventually
after days perhaps they stick together
and you make a big atom this is one of
your new elements and the elements the
atom flies off from the target to a
detector and we gets the detector you
may still be unlucky and you may all
fall to bits we feel really lucky little
bits fall off particle 1 particle of for
another and if you do very clever
measurements from the way that these
particles are formed you can work out
what the original Latin was and so you
can say I've discovered a new element
[Applause]
well this is the door to protect the
people outside from x-rays in the
accelerator tunnel here very important
for the health of see colleagues the
door has a weight of approximately 70
tons because it's filled was left we're
finally here in the linear accelerator
Hall where they accelerate the ions so
the ions stop behind this wall behind me
and they go down quite a narrow tube so
the tube is quite narrow about 30
millimetres diameter and inside that
there is the beam of ions so let's walk
along and see where the ion scope
[Applause]
by the time we get to here the ions
already traveling at five percent of the
speed of light so they accelerates
enormously faster than a car or
something like that because they're so
light and when they get to here this is
the so called stripper which strips off
more electrons so they can accelerate
the ions even faster so let's keep going
and see where the experiment is so as we
go along here the ions are going faster
and faster and faster all the time
inside the tube so here we're nearly at
the end of the accelerator and the
experiment is over there
30 meters behind that wall and we'll go
around and see it in a minute the ions
here are accelerated and you can choose
the speed if you're driving the Machine
flat out they can go up to 20% of the
speed of light but that's actually too
much energy for making the elements so
for the elements you settle for only 10%
of the speed of the light and the way
you make them go fast is by putting in
energy from radio waves I've just been
told by Ingo here from TSI that these
radio waves really are the same
frequency as broadcast and twenty years
ago the American forces Network which
used to broadcast in Germany used to
increase their transmission power at
five o'clock when the soldiers went for
their tea and they could notice this in
the beam because all their control
circuits suddenly responded to the
increased power of the radio station
[Music]
so now we go to the region which is
usually closed during experiment because
there we have radiation inside so now
this is the place where the new elements
are actually produced
so here's as the targets are mounted the
beam is coming from here from the
accelerator which we have seen along the
tube here since the beam is directed
into the centre of the target
and I can show you just such a target
wheel which we use here here you see
such a target wheel which is mounted on
the axis of sis motor here it's an it's
like this in the beam the beam hits the
targets here and seveal rotates is about
1000 level Lucian's per minute
yaw here you see the original of our
target box and all the six elements
which were made at GSI were made here in
this box
[Music]
[Applause]
I will show you the biggest secret now
so this is now our detector yeah yeah
and here's the ions are coming from the
separator and they are implanted into a
silicon detector and this detector is
now within this box and now I will show
you how it looks like and I will open
the box I'm very excited never seen
anything like this before so it's really
a real first for me I've never met
anybody who's discovered an element so
now you see our secret you see this is
the main part for the identification a
detection of the elements the beam comes
from here and sits detector is then
mounted in this direction now the whole
system is cooled to minus 20 degrees and
this gives us a much better energy
resolution when a particle comes into
the detector we measure the time when it
survived and this kiddin be done within
a microsecond curacy then we measure the
energy of the particle which comes into
the detector and we measure at which
place in the detector and this we can do
with acquisition of 0.1 millimeter yeah
usually it is hidden in the vacuum box
and you don't see it I just opened it to
show it to you this is a piece of
history suddenly our first version which
we had is already in a museum in the
torture museum in one now and it's
already a second version in post one the
obvious detector in the museum we solve
the elements hundred seven hundred eight
hundred nine and with each detector we
saw under ten eleven and twelve
you
[Music]